[Musique]
dans le cadre de sa visite officielle à
la Réunion suite au passage du cyclone
Béal géralde daranin ministre des outres
mères est allé à la rencontre des
agriculteurs au tampon avec les élus et
les représentants du monde agricole il a
pu constater une partie de l'étendue des
dégâs sur le territoire alors tous les
fonds possibles sont débloqués on va
faire une réunion on a déjà fait une
première réunion à l'aéroport ce matin
avec Monsieur le Préfet j'aurai un dîner
de travail tout à l'heure avant de
repartir à Paris évidemment tous les
moyens du ministère des outr mèes de
l'ensemble du gouvernement est à
disposition le président de la
République des consignes extrêmement
clair on est sur exp une exploitation
agricole aujourd'hui qui a tout perdu
donc l'essentiel de de sa production de
maréchage plein champ souser je sais pas
la Chambre d'Agriculture nous nous dira
le chiffre quels sont les les les
volumes impactés et après
malheureusement ben voilà nous on est on
est autosuffisant à 70 80 % par exemple
sur les fruits et légumes à la Réunion
quand sur une période comme ça un
passage de cyclone où finalement on a
plus on a plus rien le ministre a
affirmé que des moyens seront débloqués
rapidement géralde daranin a salué les
hommes de la sécurité civile du sud de
la France et les sapeurs pompiers de
Mayotte venus en renfor sur l'île ils
vont prêter main forte au sapeurs
pompiers de la Réunion et au fazoil
mobilisés dès le passage du cyclone sur
lîle je pense qu'il y a une très grande
solidarité d'abord il y a des réunionnés
très mobilisés c'est le cas bien sûr des
policiers des gendarmes des militaires
des policiers municipaux des saort
pompiers d' 10 de la Réunion et puis
tous les les agents de l'État et des
collectivités locales he madame la mère
est à mes côté elle a beaucoup d'agents
évidemment pour déblayer aider la
population comme nous l'avons décidé
avec le président de la République nous
avons envoyé des unités de de militaire
de la sécurité civile qui dépend du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui sont
spécialisés bien sûr dans ce genre
d'événement le déblayage des routes par
exemple et c'est vraiment quelque chose
de très important parce que il faut
aller très vite je je salue vraiment le
le renfort national qui va permettre en
tout cas nos équipes mobilisées
maintenant ant depuis plus de 72 he déjà
de faire une pause mais également cette
équipe en renfort va permettre de
renforcer nos nos sapeurs sur le terrain
par rapport au travail qui est déjà
engagé
587 agents du 10 sont été déployé sur
les 28 centres et également 12 postes de
sécurité avancé ont pu mettre la
population réunionnaise en sécurité
pendant cette période le président du
Département a demandé à l'état la
reconnaissance de catastrophe naturelle
pour l'ensemble des communes de lillele
suite au passage du cyclone Béal les
réunions ministérielles sont en cours en
ce
[Musique]
moment